I've said it before and I'll say it
again
the most persecuted group in America is
Trump supporters followed closely by
people who say Barnes and Nobles instead
of Barnes and Noble
this persecution of Trump supporters is
unrelenting case in point a New York
City judge wills that it is okay for bar
owners to throw out Trump supporters
throwing out Greg p8x lawsuit after he
claims he was thrown out of a bar for
wearing the make America great again cap
the man argued that hat represented his
spiritual belief as an American however
the bars lawyer argued that only
religious beliefs are protected under
discrimination laws and supporting
president Trump is not a religion
supporting President Trump is not a
religion o one event we follow an
all-powerful beam
expect him to do the impossible and
ignore all empirical evidence Plus every
Sunday we study his divine words to try
and figure out who he might fire next
sure sounds like a religion to me this
Greg Pia tick is an American slash
religious hero and not all heroes wear
capes some wear button-downs and SPF
infinity war craig is a victim of
religious persecution his lawyer whom he
definitely didn't hire from a high
school debate club told the judge that
the make America great again hat was
part of his spiritual belief exactly
Greg's hat is part of his spiritual
belief it's no different from those
Buddhist monk robes that say grab him by
the
Gregg Pia tics religious freedom was
violated when the bartender refused to
serve him another jalapeno margarita
it's like when Joan of Arc was burned by
that bartender who cut her off after
only six Raz teenies no sure a rep from
the bar said that Gregg was asked to
leave after being verbally abusive to
the staff but in makka ism being
verbally abusive is a religious custom
like mocking a woman's appearance and
then making her husband phone bank for
you now
Gregg is a martyr in the name of Maha
and for more I'd like to bring out one
of Mogga isms earliest disciples citizen
journalist Tim Balz
welcome Tim praise be Jordan bless it is
the Gorsuch under his tweets no
collusion them Tim how excited are you
to finally have Mogga ism recognized as
a religion it's about time Jordan I mean
think about it
what is a Mogga hat but a yarmulke that
blocks the Sun and starts fights we wear
this red garment to remind ourselves
that the divine presence of Trump is
always above us and also because wind is
evil and sometimes exposes the bald spot
on the back of our head so true Tim I
mean a trump rally is basically a
spiritual and sometimes violent
megachurch sermon exactly Jordan Mogga
is our Creed and president Trump is our
Savior and sure Jesus could turn water
into wine but Trump can turn a casino
into an abandoned building a casino
losing money that's a miracle yes praise
be praise be praise be crazy
big raise been raised big and yet still
this bar cast greg out where he wandered
into exile probably across the street to
Wicked Willy's for two-for-one shots of
Goldschlager
I love Goldschlager the perfect alcohol
Jordan it's like getting little bits of
Trump inside of you
but this persecution Jordan plain and
simple there's only one group of people
that deserve to be kicked out refugees
and daca kids and trans people from the
military oh and of course crying babies
I love having a baby crying while I'm
speaking you can get the baby out of
here it's just like Jesus said at his
Sermon on the Mount get that baby out of
here
my point is Greg is a martyr and his
sacrifice has made every elitist New
York City Bar a holy site and Jordan I'm
not ashamed to make my pilgrimage to
these holy sites five to seven times a
week don't worry I can stop whenever so
yesterday I went out to practice my
religious beliefs with the opposition
credit-card roll it but what what did
you do I said roll it
[Music]
No
yeah I'm not
[Music]
we're going back to you Tim thanks to
enqueue Tim the fight continues
[Music]